these days no one like people don't have
that excuse anymore like if someone is
even entertaining the thought of being a
writer there are a zillion interviews
with professional writers out there sure
someone wants to be an entrepreneur
there are a zillion interviews with
entrepreneurs where they're literally
talking about how much money they're
making yeah similarly for YouTube and
stuff and so surrounding I think in
information diet is a really important
part of this like even just watching
videos reading books and listening to
podcasts from people who are doing the
thing that you think you want to do
helps you realize that oh are fair
Fairly normal they've just been doing it
for a while and oh that's what the
outcome could look like yeah like look
if you're
no one no one goes it must be impossible
to be an accountant how does someone
become an accountant right because you
accountants are everywhere right
although you know if you grew up in the
inner city and your parents didn't work
and you never had it might actually seem
utterly unattainable and impossible to
become that thing and the reality is
it's not people do it every
day